[Music]
Cole pepper Sarah
Troy's an Jerri thank you for a great
final tribal I will see everybody back
in the States for the reading of the
votes
the competition was stiffer than ever on
Wednesdays finale of Survivor Bain
changers as the remaining castaways vied
for that million-dollar prize the winner
of Survivor game changes another big
moment
Zeke Smith and Jeff Varner reunited
after Varner outed Zeke as transgender
during the season I was really scared
um he's I I didn't know what was gonna
happen to my world I didn't I didn't
know what the reaction was gonna be but
what this experience has shown me is
that I so much love in my life I got hit
hard we knew we would you told me I
would prepare yourself and it was really
ugly for a period of time but then it
changed
he was that he is happy about the love
in his life I'm thrilled with the
support in mind it Zeke also shared how
survivor helped him cope during his
transition when I transitioned I was hit
with a pretty big bout of depression and
I started watching Survivor and I just i
binge 20 seasons and it took me away in
so many ways survivor and Stephen Eberle
et spoke with Zeke after Wednesday's
finale now that the show has wrapped he
has his eyes set on Hollywood quote I've
always wanted to be on television and to
write and to maybe even have my own show
one day
you